what happened to daily Vlogs and do you
see them making a comeback in 2023 great
question my boy we're filming one right
now yeah I do see it coming back I don't
know if you heard that there was this
thing called covid
I'm a purebred entrepreneur for real for
real for real like documented sunshine
[Music]
Vayner Nation what is good another live
podcast not clips from a talk or a video
but an actual podcast that I know you
love and I think you're gonna really
love this one uh my guest today is
someone I adore Ryan Smith is a
tremendous entrepreneur who built a very
large business and then created an
opportunity for himself to now be the
owner of the Utah Jazz especially
excited to have him on because we're
recording this a mere 10 or so days
before All-Star Weekend in Utah Ryan
thanks for being on the show gee what's
up hey anytime man I'm excited for for
everything that's coming what was the
most surprising thing for you in reality
of owning a sports team you know I was
looking at another team because that's
what's available you don't you just like
the NFL like if you want to own a team
or you're in a position fortunately that
you might be able to play in that space
timing is very very hard like the Utah
Jazz have been in one family the Millers
who had done an incredible job for 35
years you know it was never going to
leave the family and so when we got a
chance to do this I think there's two
things Adam said hey Ryan if you're
lucky to be a part of the NBA like
that's great but no one gets their team
a year earlier you're going to these
games and you're a super fan of the guys
and team now you're the owner how tough
was that to translate from fan to friend
to now you have to detach from both
feelings be in a conference room and
like make decisions that are in the best
interest of the franchise it's super
difficult uh because you care deeply
about people I'm a people person life's
about people I I think you've got to
take a step back and say hey like we're
all in the NBA you're gonna have to make
tough decisions you have to be able to
manage polar opposite emotions brother I
love you can't wait to see you thanks
Ryan all right we'll see you bro
[Music]
I am very honored to have the privilege
of introducing Gary McIntosh
[Applause]
AI is the tractor and for the people who
understand what I'm saying here it is
most people worked on farms back in the
day and then a tractor came out and
everyone's like [__] that
this is going to ruin the world we're
all out of [__] jobs and then people
found new jobs so what do I think you
can have any opinion you want technology
doesn't give a [__] about your opinion
all right I gotta go back to work thank
you for having me
sure of course of course thank you so so
much of course
it's really helped me thank you thank
you so much you're welcome are we on
time what time is it it is 25. so is my
next thing in five minutes
um yes that was really good it was
really good it's awesome
oh yeah ladies and gentlemen Gary
Patrick
dude it's been a year or so since we got
to hang out before first of all thank
you this has been very fun for me but
two podcasts with you have been
incredible the community that that I've
been working with just loves your
content and so one of my favorite
talking points you have is this thing of
slow down the macro and speed up the
micro people get confused on this
because you talk a lot about patients
too and they think that means well I
should just go slow well for some reason
people have decided to turn the word
patience into passiveness that's yeah
when I say be patient I don't mean lay
on your couch and watch TV I mean stand
up people don't understand this so if
someone's never heard the slow down the
macro speed up the micro what does that
mean expand that your day-to-day go way
faster be way more efficient but macro
I'm not in a rush to buy the New York
Jets your day to day like this is my
calendar yeah like it's constant look at
these meetings 11 to 1105 five minute
meeting 11 05 to 11 30 11 30 11 45 11 45
to 12 1205 to 12 30
15 meetings before 1 pm today so that's
speed up your micro everyone needs to
really really really really really speed
up their day-to-day
but slow their skis on their big goals
enjoy the process don't rush to get the
trophy all right so I did something fun
uh with my community you know Gary lots
of people want access to you and you
know you're busy
um and you love q a I've seen you at
this stuff so I asked um some of my
buddies on the internet if they have a
question for you I love it record it
let's do it I'll play it and so I got
some people that jumped in let's go what
happened to daily Vlogs and do you see
them making a comeback in 2023 great
question yeah my boy we're filming one
right now yeah I do see it coming back I
don't know if you heard but there was
this thing called covid I'm weird yeah
Google it c-o-v-i-d it was a thing it
happened it kind of [__] up the flow
uh but I think we'll be back and I
expect by 2024. I can sense myself
getting close by the way you get out of
practice that's true dust how many
things have I said I don't want to film
that would have been insane I would have
been upset if you didn't film three
years ago true really out of practice
yeah yeah I think I think we are going
to be more than back daily so you think
the blog space personal blog space is
going to start people should pay
attention to that potentially for their
own business and branding and marketing
efforts yeah documenting over creating I
mean it's everything look my friend you
gotta go yeah I know you do but thank
you dude it's been a great time together
I appreciate you so much for being such
an iconic podcast Panther
it's it's been a lot of fun that was
awesome it's [__] like actually
awesome dailyvee crew uh really really
appreciate the feedback but a lot of it
I'm getting an email in other forms
leave a question in the comments so that
I can answer it on the next dailyvee I
need to answer some of your questions I
need it YouTube I need it
[Music]
foreign